e
so good morning morning welcome to
division one of the finance committee
first we have uh House Bill
1178 we did have a work session on this
uh back on the 6th of March I see
representative Cahill here I believe
there's an amendment that's being
offered by representative Maguire and
grassie Amendment
1120h and either representative Maguire
did representative grassy work with me
our uh M Mr chair you would I have yet
another
amendment in the works right now uh
waiting for the the the ol blessing and
the but that would combine this text
with it yet another
tweak to make someone else happy so if
we wanted to say the Pledge of
Allegiance real
slow you know before we get going here
maybe that maybe my maybe the email will
arrive but I can describe for you what
it does in addition to
this first before you move forward I
guess a question for representative
Maguire and grassy I think of a
different we have we have another one
right so per the email discussion I have
copies of um representative
infant's yeah
infantine that's a different amount okay
that's why I'm confused okay so
representative infantine asked for a
different Amendment which he told me he
would be here to talk about but he's not
so I don't know what to do and this is
on
okay but I don't think I
didn't but
thanks
so before we go any further I fail to
recognize representative barudi who will
be subbing for representative hu it for
those of you that don't know Benny
served on finance for a while and he was
my vice chair when I served his chair a
while ago so know Ben well and don't
tell any good stories representative
thank you Mr chairman I just want to say
that we have granted representative
uh he he told me this morning I wish you
again okay
all right so all
right you have a an amendment for US
Representative that's the one that was
just handed
okay this the one we were waiting for so
maybe
infant let me
see that was my
plan all right I have the I have the
amendment in here let me yeah well we we
let the representative from Manchester
go first just so since we don't have a
draft of your Amendment and uh
here guys you're welcome to come forward
and once you get there just state your
please good morning Mr chairman my name
is will infantine uh from Hillsboro 16
in Manchester and I'm the chairman of
the labor committee and I have been on
the labor committee for the last 16
years you know it's
really something to say about
institutional knowledge over the years
of being on the committee you realize
what is things that the labor committee
should be doing and things they
shouldn't be
doing there's a myriad of different
businesses out there and we think of the
most simple someone that works at a a a
gas station um a real estate agent a
doctor a nurse you know all these
different things but there's all kinds
of goofy jobs out there that you don't
really think about and because those
jobs are tailored to sometimes the
Seasons businesses have to come up with
their own ideas as how to deal with that
right now in the North Country right now
the snow's going away
it's mud season some people have to get
laid off for a certain period of time
until it's time for the spring and the
summer activities there's a company in
Manchester that makes chocolate and they
close down every June to retool their
entire
Factory paving companies make decisions
during the year to withhold some of
their wages from their
employees at the employees uh um in
agreement
so when they're off in two or 3 months
they don't necessarily have to get
unemployment which as we all know
doesn't pay 35 or 40% of your lost
income so businesses have to make these
changes that affect you
know what what their business model is I
let all my employees off at 1:00 on
Fridays because we don't get any phone
calls one person stays behind and
everyone gets a nice long weekend these
are just decisions that businesses make
so we're very careful when we try to
make law that it doesn't affect this
this narrow band of what you think is is
a standard business because there's all
kinds of things out there um that you on
a daily basis you don't really realize
what other other businesses are doing so
we like to let the employer make some
decisions within reason obviously for
safety and other
things so when we make these decisions
are we pigeon ho holding a company into
something are we making them do what the
legislature wants versus what's tailored
for their
business this bill has come in front of
the committee six or eight times in the
last eight or nine years and every time
I try to work with the um the sponsor
who I respect for continuing to push the
way he does to try to get something
passed there are two circumstances which
we have heard that I feel is something
that be is fair to both the employer and
the employee and that has to do with
when um a business
closes well there's no other way to get
some of those extra
benefits that they have AC crude time so
there should be a mechanism there how
about secondly when a business is sold
to another business and that business
that's purchasing them does not accept
that that um earn time those are two
things the sponsor of the bill and I
agree
on those are circumstances that are
unique enough that I feel that it's okay
for the legislature to make some
decisions but the way the current bill
is drafted I have a couple problems with
it number one I think it preempts Union
contracts I think it preempts uh
people's procedures manual and I don't
think we should be doing that so I've
tried to come up with an amendment that
hits those two
items doesn't deal with the un uh
unemployed uh people that uh
um for some reason the company says we
have to have a
layoff and you don't know whether you're
going to come back on and up by and
large people do bring them back but
there's all kinds of things that anyone
would ever think in this room that Co
was going to
happen or you know so things
happen so I'm trying to to my Amendment
tries to take the items that I feel are
the most
important those two we men the only
other change I made and and not this is
arbitrary I tried to split the
difference here between people who
wanted employers no more than 15 or 15
employers or less other people wanted 25
I split the difference in 20 I
understand there are other things in New
Hampshire law that 15 is consistent I
really don't care either
way but the the the real problem I have
is
when making some arbitrary comments like
well well when there's no reasonable
expect ation that you might be
reemployed I mean that when you're
sitting here and say you're all hearing
officers for the Department of Labor how
do you adjudicate that kind of language
and we try to be very
specific in the labor committee as
president of Broody knows full well for
his many years on the committee try to
make it so you don't have such an
arbitrary thing for Department of Labor
hearing officers to try to have to
figure
out so that is my stance um on this bill
and and
the things that I feel that it would be
appropriate uh for the legislature to
come down and and say that this is
appropriate and this is fair another
thing I've learned over my years of of
sitting here in the legislature is I do
not like to pass legislation for the
sake of passing legislation in New
hampsh in in in the house when I know
full well it probably has no
chance um I know we don't have to worry
about the other side of the wall and all
so I I I don't want to pass anything
that's not going to have a chance of
becoming law it just it's kind of a
waste of everyone's
time you take questions yes I'm happy to
represent Maguire fall B represent
Kimbrell uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative for coming um we've
talked you you mentioned to me
previously about a seasonal employment
how does this affect that is is and is
that a problem with the current bill I
believe the current bill does have a
problem with seasonal employment because
of that whole that concept of reasonable
expectation of when you'll be um brought
back we're going to have hey ice out we
just broke the record by one day okay um
I've already you know I know people are
already hey let's get the boat ready
know let's let's get let's get things
moving skis are away let's start doing
the things that that we want to do we
never know from any year what's going to
happen the asphalt plants are going to
be open earlier this year a light mud
season construction is going to start
earlier so you never know any given time
and what happens if it takes uh 6 weeks
versus four weeks to retool that
chocolate factory in Manchester and and
people are out for a little longer than
expected so you know because of uh our
seasonality because of our weather
obviously you know you never know as an
employer
I think this pigeon holes a little bit
sorry represent cell thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for that
clear concise presentation I have been
one who have has opposed this bill for
the past several years but I can tell
you that I agree with everything you
said and that I can support this
questions I do have one often we we get
criticized here in finance because we're
a policy committee with a little p
versus the policy committee that you
chair and U just want to caution
everybody that all these bills coming in
these Amendments have nothing to do with
Finance of the state cers like this
amendment here is a policy change so
again just a reminder this bill did go
before the house came out of the
committee as a 1010 split I believe
correct and then there was a Voice vote
on the house to uh support an amendment
which did pass and there was a Voice
vote to uh pass it back I think on
February 22nd so I agree with you um you
know the way I was always taught uh when
it comes to finance it's about financial
and it's not a policy so that's why I
was reticent to kind of bring this in
from a finance standpoint if this
affects the state and the and the
municipal um and you have that uh
paragraph in there about reasonable
assumption uh you could possibly have
people who work for the uh any
municipality that may be laid off for
any certain period of time that could
um utilize that clause and and try to
get whatever um um unused earn time or
whatever they have and of course as you
know State and
municipalities when they pay out workers
compensation they must reimburse
unemployment Securities so there is
potential cost
there
are there any further questions yeah
Melissa please I just wanted to make a
little bit of a clarifying statement
that this actually this RSA does not
pertain to state or Municipal Employees
they are exempt from this RSA well thank
you it does impact um the university
system though that was my not my
understanding but thank
you I have heard from uh employers of
the state that are quite concerned that
the state has removed themselves and yet
the state is pushing legislation that
will affect businesses and the state
doesn't follow their own advice so just
that that's out
there that that is common theme uh in
the committee as well labor committee as
well thank
you are there any further questions for
the representative from Manchester
seeing represent Bui have a question I
see a reaching for the mic not really
but I think if the state of New
Hampshire sells the business that uh the
new state should take it over
thank you all right we do have an
amendment on the floor is uh anyone
interested in moving it along
um 1047 AG but should we hear from
represent
first I thought there was an agreement
but representative K representative kill
you don't like this amendment I I do
okay could you please come forward then
we'll hold off on the amendment I thank
you misunderstood I thought there was
kind of an agreement among the parties
on this but apparently not no yes thank
you Mr chairman uh Michael Cahill
representing Rockingham 10 the
communities of newfields and New Market
and yet another amendment hot off the
press still warm the um as you may
recall we we did have an ISS that we
discovered after passing the house that
the uh the issue trying to accommodate
the seasonal employers was a little bit
too open where there was we forgot to
put in the language that it was a
layoff and so that's been addressed here
but combined with that we have put in a
cap of 30 days for the amount of time
time that would be reimbursed and that's
is because as uh uh representative
grassy alluded to earlier uh you
University New Hampshire has an
extremely
generous uh package a program that they
use when someone is laid off and we
don't we certainly don't want to harm
people who are already being well taken
care of by by minimizing that but what
we're trying to do is take care of the
people who with this rather broad brush
of a we don't pay uh upon termination we
don't pay vacation time that's rather
broad brush that that impacts people who
can least afford
it and that's why I object to uh the
amendment from the gentleman my chairman
of my committee with whom I've worked on
this issue for many years because his
Amendment removes people who are laid
off which I think is the more likely of
the circumstances that could occur uh
yes a business is sometimes sold and a
business sometimes is closed but uh a
layoff is something that may happen a
few times during the course of a
business it could happen and when the
person is laid off uh they do go and and
file a claim for unemployment and if
they have if they've been paid vacation
their vacation time that they earned uh
then the claim will be delayed
protecting the education the sorry the
uh the uh unemployment trust fund and
giving them really what they've earned
what they're entitled to what what was
what they were offered and what they've
acquired AC Creed or not over during the
course of their employment and again
this is this as this is well the uh
other other circumstances is it no fault
to the employee and they should not uh
lose what they've earned because because
some things are slow with the business
or whatever is happening so uh that is
why I'm hoping that you will pass this
amendment uh 20241 256h which combines
both of the fixes that this bill needs
to once again pass the house and I
believe perhaps pass the Senate as
there's no longer the language that
allows for someone to be paid uh because
they have given proper notice and work
their notice and leaving on good terms
that was removed that was that was an
impediment for some and
uh uh Mr juv is here for the business
and industry Association we I also have
uh a good uh neutral from the U
Municipal Association and I believe uh
usnh will be happy that I've added this
30-day cap that was their that was their
remaining objection so it's been it's
been altered to accommodate as many
people as possible and again the number
of people as I as I provided to you with
information from the uh Economist at the
employment security that basically 84%
of the Employers in New Hampshire will
not be affected by
this because that number 15 which again
I showed you has several different uh
similar triggers s events uh raising it
to 20 maybe that'll maybe that'll only
cover uh 82% I don't know but I think
that I think uh the L with the the 15 is
is a good number it was provided to me
by the former Deputy Commissioner of
labor for those reasons because it was
not a new number for for employers to
deal with the uh small companies uh
under 15 employees are are exempt and
the
uh the uh
it is now clarified because if the
business Clos change ownership or a
layoff with no reasonable Assurance now
I know that my my good friend Mr infant
time was struggling with this thing
about seasonality and we talk about
reasonable you know does is H is ice out
a factor in your returning to work well
okay ice out has happened I'm sure the
employee isn't going to demand all their
back pay or their vacation because
they're going to be working uh a week
later or a week ear you know
people are
reasonable and and I think uh that's
that takes care of the uh the the
concern with the paving as you don't
know when spring is here today but it
might not be here tomorrow because we're
in New Hampshire but you know people are
reasonable if you're going back to a job
because you know and you intend to go
back the employer intends to hire you
you're not going to make a fuss because
something was off a little
bit uh I also want to tell you that if
you do file a claim uh with employment
with the U Department of labor the the
claimant has the burden to prove you
have to prove that you were that the
policy or the practice was or the law
was not followed it's it's not an easy
task uh you have to have records you
have to have that everything in order
and uh where where someone is laid off
uh they haven't been collecting all
these records perhaps you know but the
layoff a layoff enough a layoff as it is
should be should be enough to guarantee
that you'll receive what whatever time
you had coming to you that You' work to
earn with the understanding that that
was part of your package part of your
employment you get this wage you get
This Much Vacation whatever whatever
they're calling it and we're excluded
the sick days because I never intended
for six days to be reimbursed because we
hope you don't get sick but the
employers do want you to take the
vacation to use the time to be refresh
be productive and it's an offered as
something to retain workers it's not
intended I I don't think is something
that I can hold on to in case the person
leaves and I've got this much more money
than I had than I would have had if I
have actually paid them what I was
supposed to pay them uh if you have a if
you have a small if you have a business
like this I think you have a small
business indeed but uh so I urge you to
pass this amendment and we'll go back to
the floor or in the alternative like
I'll bring it as a floor Amendment and I
think the votes are there because uh we
hear a lot about you know Workforce and
Workforce uh not many Workforce people
in the legislature but working people of
a working class have either seen this
happen or they seen it not happen and
they know that this is the right thing
to do so I think I think either way it
will pass on the floor I'd rather have
it coming out of this committee amended
than do that and that's what I'm asking
you to do
today are there any questions for
representative kale and I again just
reminding the committee uh when we took
up this bill we heard there was going to
be one simple Amendment but we now have
three
amendments uh so those of you that have
come for other meetings or hearings I
apologize for the delay uh represent
Maguire yeah I'll just State and I I
would hope that representative grassy
would agree that this latest Amendment
from representative kahill is an
improvement over the one we created for
representative kill so so we can ignore
the one that has my name on it I
think yeah this this is the combination
so all
good yeah good okay see so that means I
may not have to Fe on all right let me
let me um ask a question
so technically what does the word does
the word layoff apply if if somebody say
like a ski instructor and the ski season
ends and and maybe they would come back
to work next year as a ski instructor
and maybe not who knows um is that a
layoff or is that something else I I I'm
not sure if ski instructors get vacation
time as it is a seasonal thing and I
know there's something strange in the
law an exception for people working at
ski resorts oh I I can't put my finger
on it right now but it is something
resorts I used to be a ski instructor
myself so I can probably answer the
question and bus dri school school bus
drivers and ski instructors well I used
to teach skiing at Temple Mountain
before they closed in Peterboro Temple
and we used to be able to ski anywhere
in the country for free that was one of
our benefits but we did not get any
layoff for right vacation time and I
think Mr chairman as you've been here
longer than I you may recall a time when
when uh Representatives could skeg and
New Hampshire for free at least at the
state own places yes we changed that all
right so maybe skiing is somehow special
so so let me try something else you you
work at an ice cream stand right and
it's the end of Summer and the ice cream
stand closes for the winter right is
that a layoff or is that something else
um well it if you have the if you okay
you are I guess it's a layoff or it's
just closed for the season you can say
the business closes I don't think people
working on ice cream stands are getting
vacation time but if they did I bet that
employer would pay them because they
went they went through the trouble of
offering that vacation time so they'll
all be scooping and not uh not looking
for people to do that so I mean maybe
the manager gets some something I don't
know the manager yeah the manager may
get or maybe he goes uh to another
operation in the warmer climate and
Scoops ice cream there all right or
becomes a ski instructor I don't
know represent grassy would you like to
speak to the amendment yeah yeah
certainly and I and I and I think that
what you're looking at and and some of
the these seasonal businesses a lot of
place they don't have vacation time
because you're on your vacation time
when the season ends and and so this
only deals with the crude time and this
is something that I personally
experienced when covid hit uh it hit in
March my business the business that I
worked for shut down those what the
first year you worked for the company
you got no vacation time your vacation
time AC Creed in January so on January
1st you got your first week or your two
weeks or your three weeks which I happen
to have been at at that time and those
people that took their vacations between
January and March 15th got their
vacation time those people who didn't
which I was one had three weeks vacation
was planning on taking it in August got
nothing didn't get a check for the
vacation time which was a crew that I
had worked the whole previous year to
get got
nothing so that's what this bill is
attempting to
address that those people who work it
the crude vacation time would be in your
policy most seasonal businesses don't
have that so this addresses a crude
vacation time that's offered by
businesses if the businesses don't offer
vacation time then there's nothing there
out uh yes representative kill quickly
please because I'd like to uh recognize
a gentleman from the bi I oh I recognize
him too I think I'm glad to see him here
yeah yeah so yes I just wanted to
clarify you know you're just looking at
the amendment but the bill itself is
only to employers of 15 or more who
offer vacation pay time off so if you
have 20 employees and you don't offer
vacation you might find it harder to
keep people but you know you at least
you don't have to pay their vacation so
and so the bill is really finally
finally tuned with I think everything I
can think of at the present time to
please very ious entities and I ask you
to pass the amendment and the bill I
testimony and if you could please state
your name for the record please thank
you Mr chair for the record my name is
Dave ju I'm senior vice president for
public policy with the Bia I I fear my
comments May further confuse the
committee
but
bia's preference frankly would be that
you don't do anything that you don't
pass this
legislation um we were neutral on
representative K Hill's
proposal um because in the spirit of
kindness and fairness we wanted to try
to find some middle ground for those
employees who through no fault of their
own um had a crude time that they never
had the opportunity to use use we didn't
support the bill but we didn't oppose it
uh we do recognize it creates some
questions and will likely create some
disputes and part of the reason for all
the Amendments is to try and uh nail
down the language in such a way that
it'll reduce the disputes um in terms of
Representative infantine bill I think um
that would be closer to what the Bia
would have ultim wanted which is nothing
at all it certainly takes away the
question about uh layoffs um and will
only affect those businesses that either
permanently close or are sold to a new
owner and the owner won't recognize the
acred time um so from that sense I would
say that's the better of the two
amendments but it's only from our
perspective which is we would have
preferred not to see any legislation at
all happy to answer any
questions representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman thank you
for coming so what would you say to
representative grass's personal
circumstance um what happened to him
when he was laid off um well I think
that illustrates part of uh what could
be the confusion that will result from
the legislation and again we're neutral
on representative K Hill's proposal for
example um many businesses including the
ones the one that I work for was shut
down by executive order during the early
days of covid we continued to get paid
because in my case I was able to work
remotely and other employees from other
businesses around the state got paid
because of the um the uh payroll
Protection Program and if they didn't
get that uh for example my wife didn't
get it she was employed but she was able
to file for unemployment and was able to
receive essentially the full amount of
her salary because of the federal
additions to the unemployment
benefit um in many cases those
businesses that were shut down opened up
again once they were allowed to and all
those individuals who were
employed were employed again so
um again the question
is if they were laid off was that for a
uh with a reasonable expect expectation
that they wouldn't be reemployed and I
would suspect most of the businesses
where that happened they were assuring
their employees that once we're able to
open again we'll want you to come back
for work but I think everyone recognizes
there's a little bit of grayness to that
um we all have different uh concepts of
what reasonable is but In fairness to
represent of Cahill uh we did think
there was some fairness to try to deal
with employees who were laid off
permanently uh and never had the
time so just so I'm clear the bill that
came out and was amended by the house
back in February you're okay with that
but you oh no not okay with that at all
no we were absolutely not okay with that
we think the amendment the floor
amendment that passed in the house
opened up the door so that any
individual whose employment was
terminated for any reason could uh would
be required to receive the uh acred but
unused time we ABS I don't think that
was the intent of the sponsor of the
floor Amendment but that's what the
did
thank you Mr chair again at at the end
of the day and I know we're not supposed
to talk policy but I believe like uh
even in the representative's case over
here when he took that job he would have
known what the policy was and if he
didn't get uh vacation that would have
simply been the company's policy um so
again uh I I would I I would prefer no
bill but if we must go forward again I I
can support Port representative in
STI okay we do have a hand waving back
there again I remind everyone we're way
behind schedule not no fault of anyone
sitting out there but all
H representative grassy has a question
yeah just just a comment because was one
of the things that was said is that when
you get laid off you does it tend to get
hired again the company that I worked
for was closed down quite a while
because of covid when they came back
they hired a number of employees back
those employees all started off as as
new employees they did not get any of
the acred time that they had held before
they did not get any of the the other
benefits that they had they started off
with zero vacation time as and everybody
started off at the base so their ACR
time which they had earned was lost and
fair all right I have a response
to no respon
okay there is a motion on the floor was
moved by represent cell and seconded by
represent
anyway the clerk does have yeah I I just
wondered under your circumstances then
representative grassy do you not support
the infantine amendment uh certainly
because it takes layoffs out of the
equation and layoffs I think is the most
important thing you have here when
people are laid off and it may go beyond
a period of time um you know if the
place has maybe closed down for a year
or two years if they're hiring the
employees back if there's a reasonable
expectation of getting rehired I have no
problem with it as long as your benefits
are kept there so that you can get your
benefits but once those once they take
that acrude time away from you that
you've earned that's a problem and and
what happened is after four years when
they finally reopened they basically
said we're not honoring any previous we
have new Personnel policy you all come
in as new employees so it wasn't really
a it was a layoff but then it was a
termination at some point and because
they didn't bring any of those employees
back they owed us the
time I would oppose the
amendment let me get my well she's
getting set up I'm going to mix up the
voting a little bit representative wer
will be going first from now on as a
senior member of the finance committee
so I just think that's more appropriate
that so that's we change things up just
a bit when and the chair better not
forget yeah that way the clerk the clerk
won't forget him anymore she is at this
point4 and the motion is pass okay
representative chair yes um
representative yes representa yes
representa
yes
no
all right the infantine amendment passes
as you heard five the
four and we will move to the next uh
action ought to pass as amended I'll
move out to pass as
amended with the understanding that
speech M just just a comment Mr chairman
I would oppose this uh basically what
it's done is gutted the bill the bill is
yes I heard sweed's name in there in
Maguire is that
swe
the
yes
noes
no
no so we do still have an amendment that
was offered by representative um Grassi
that well it's still it's been submitted
the bill could be amended again if you
want wish to move your motion or we can
just let it you can withdraw it's up to
you
may I we open to further am always are
offered
yeah okay that's fine and the minority
amendment can be in the
calendar right yeah
yeah all right um that concludes our
action on 1178
this will be before the full committee I
chairman
yeah and next we have House Bill
1666 relative to income reporting
requirements for
lobbyists I see the deputy secretary of
state here I assume you're here for this
no do we have an amendment for this uh
Melissa as well I believe you have a
revised fiscal note just no amendment to
this
bill all right we do have a revised
fiscal note on yes representa Sweeney
sorry I would move off to pass on HB
1666 thank you it's been moved and
seconded by representative
[Music]
thanks for doing
that say something if you want to say
something yeah so this is this seems to
be just a one-time cost for um for
computers updates so it's not I think
the bill as
originally came out had more expense but
this is fairly minimal
so thank you so for the clerk um it was
moved by representative Sweeney seconded
by representative grassy to uh approve
language
um chair wer
yes representative Maguire yes Griffin
yes yes Sweeny yes Ambrose yes clerk
votes yes barudi yes grassy yes Lehman
yes all right nine
nothing all right you can write another
committee report thank you
Joe all right moving to
1577 relative to digital images of
ballots Aaron you have anything to on
this one or do we also have a
uh I don't see a new fiscal
note Melissa uh this hearing was just
continued from last week I believe
representative Maguire was hoping or may
have worked with represent or with sorry
with Miss Hennessy on this bill but
there's no amendment to revise fiscal
it's just a continuation of the hearing
repres McGuire so I do want to amend the
bill but I don't I don't have the exact
language ready so this bill um the the
main Pro the main fiscal financial
problem with it is it wants to it it
requires an ongoing $100,000 Plus for a
new employee and at the Secretary of
State's office and and in particular
what it asks the Secretary of State to
do is gather the memory cards from these
voting machines which are located in the
in the
municipalities and then have an employee
display play the what's on the cards to
interested
parties um and and that's what the
partially what the employee is for so
what I have in mind for an amendment is
to leave the memory cards with the
municipalities and allow them to um to
sell copies of those cards to any
interested parties for their
costs um of making the making the
duplicated cards so um and just let it
go with that and and the the interested
parties can can then access the
information on their own time with their
own computer equipment and so on um it
does
um now the Secretary of State I think
might argue and and did last time that
that they're not in favor of well maybe
I shouldn't but maybe you should explain
but but they don't like the idea
necessarily of of making the the cop the
pictures of the ballots just open right
so that so that um they're easily
identifiable and so on to me you know I
think we're in this age where where
everything should be open and and um the
whatever downside there is to doing that
is very minor compared to the upside of
having open and and transparent
elections and so on now um the bill
itself does not allow full auditing of
Elections because there are always
hand-counted ballots and so the handc
counted ballots are not on the memory
cards but that wasn't the sponsor's
intention as I understand it so so
that's my thought is is take the money
out of the bill by just saying to towns
look if somebody wants want a copy of
the memory card you need to copy it and
give it to them and you can charge them
so
Aon thank you Mr chair Aon Hennessy
deputy secretary of state uh I've been
working with representative Maguire on
some questions he had about the
different memory cards of the two new
devices that the bout law conditionally
C uh conditionally CER certified one is
actually um received the conditions to
be used met the conditions to be be used
in New Hampshire elections the other has
not yet but is working towards that um
one of the devices has a off-the-shelf
USB memory card um that would be able to
be the images would be able to be viewed
per discussion with the vendor um if you
on your home computer it just might take
a little while to view each one the
other I am working with the other vendor
to figure out what would be needed in
order to number one copy those memory
cards because they are not offshelf
memory cards and I don't
know um I don't know if they are the
type of memory card that someone could
plug into a USB or a USC or a normal
port with that a normal person has with
a computer um so I'm working to get
follow-up answers on that as well as um
answers representative
wer thank you Mr chair hello eron uh if
we would to change this bill so that for
full disclosure you wouldn't deal with
any company that had something special
that couldn't be easily
copied how would that affect things you
know it obviously we want to have some
familiarity and have
everybody able to get things you know
you could Mark the ballot but do not
make any marks that
can you know identify the
individual so that somebody makes some
stupid Mark that oh that's so and so the
town idiot that did that and you know
everybody would
know he always draws the same face on
but you know other than that you know I
think for full disclosure we've had so
much in my mind cheating on ballots that
I would like full disclosure Ure and I
would I would be tempted to put it in
your amendment
that no machine could be used that was
too complicated to have the the uh
reader
copy is that a
question so you I think you would have
to change um a lot more sections of the
law and the process by which uh
electronic ballot counting devices are
approved by the ballot law
commission we can do
that it's it is your
legislative um opportunity to do
that representative grassy a question I
have you saying these cards that they
have are specific to the machines right
they're proprietary is that correct for
correct for one of the vendors okay if
they were not proprietary would that
open them up to possibly
Mischief thank you for the question so
the coding of the um of the um election
on the non proprietary USB um that is
used for a specific election if that
coding were to be changed then um it
would corrupt the data and the device
would not would know that it was changed
so there's some fancy computer stuff
going on in there that would not allow
somebody to change the coding on that um
you could still view the images of the
ballots you just can't change anything
so that somebody couldn't try and tamper
with an
election
represent Maguire thank you Mr chairman
so um first of all I want to point out
that this bill only allows the
information to be distributed after the
final date for the election so that it
cannot affect the election the election
results are known and all that sort of
stuff it's only for afterwards correct I
believe it's only for after the recount
period yes yes so that's that's the end
right so yeah is or is it not the end um
I I always hope it's the end all right
fine and then
secondly what I'm going to propose is
let's say some Town buys the the
nonproprietary non um public machine
right the the one with the proprietary
memory card well
presumably they could still sell copies
but it would be a lot more expensive
because they would go to the company and
say make me a copy of this proprietary
memory card and so they would tell the
the person who wants to buy it okay I
can do it for you but I'm going to need
$11,000 because that's what this company
charges right and so if that's
unacceptable to the election law
committee or whatever let them make
those those extensive changes saying
such a machine can't be used but I don't
think we're ready to to to make those
changes right
so yes response yeah uh thank you I I
also wasn't asked this but I do want to
point out that the um house election law
did unanimously pass this week a
post-election audit bill so that puts
back into law the post- elction audits
that were done previously in New
Hampshire at our last general election
um and we will be required to do those
um randomly selected on different
devices across the State starting um if
this bill um passes the full house
starting in the September State primary
which would read all of the ballots that
go through an electronic ballot counting
device thanks Erin so a question for
representative Maguire is your intent to
offer an amendment to remove the
$100,000
yes any representative
eil uh welcome back
um when you were here before I'm trying
to remember I you had privacy concerns
with the bill and I'm assuming even as
proposed to be amended your privacy
concerns remain you were concerned about
uh accessible
voting thank you for the question I do
still have privacy concerns and I always
have I I am in favor of transparency in
elections I just have concerns if you do
not have the full set of data um people
are apt to make judgment calls on things
that they don't have all of the
information on and that would lead to
more questions um and more
theories okay so you don't have the full
set of data and you have privacy
concerns that continue all right I just
want to get it straight
here all right so as you heard
representative Maguire does have an
amendment that we do not have but we
should have for a next work session
which will be next
so now moving on to House Bill
1589 establishing a
veterans treatment
eron and we do have some additional
information from the LBA I think we have
right
like to state your name for the record
please and the gentleman I guess next
you might like to speak to is that my
I'd like to introduce him because I
think of myself as his hypewoman um I
just go around promoting how great our
new Statewide treatment Court
coordinator Alex Cassell is uh with the
judicial branch he has been working in
the drug courts and he would be the
person who would oversee the veterans uh
courts and currently works in the
veterans track so he's here for any
policy questions you have and then also
for the record I'm Aon cre and I'm the
general counsel for the judicial
branch so I don't believe the division
had any particular problem with the bill
was just some Financial questions
represent Maguire thank you Mr chairman
so this bill sends uh roughly $2 million
a year to the counties are the counties
the ones that are experiencing expenses
if the bill passes or is that the
Judiciary is that somebody else
we do have about uh 200,000 of expenses
but uh Alex can tell you a little bit
more about how the counties work in the
drug courts
sure so the the way that the finances
would work on the adult drug court end
uh that we um contract with either the
county or a treatment agency in that
particular County to run and operate the
adult drug court uh in that jurisdiction
so the cost to the court uh would be you
know the state coordinator um and any
kind of training database that kind of
stuff that that's for the court now for
the county itself uh the the they
wouldn't have to put any um dollars into
it if if it's state funded in this the
same way that the adult drug courts are
um because the those funds fund uh
treatment case management coordination
the burden that would be on the county
would be uh staff time uh a county
attorney or assistant County attorney
that would be on the team uh maybe uh
somebody that works at the jail would be
on the team uh for Staffing and for
court so the there would be no dollar
cost there would just be ink kind you
know people's time to to work on the on
the
program follow up thank you so um but
the theory first of all it's not drug
court it's veterans court right but so
but I'm assuming all right
um the supposedly these things save
money overall in the sense that some
being treated this way is not in jail
right right and that would be a count
the expense yes or no it would be a
county or state prison expense because
not everybody that is in the the
veterans court or the adult drug court
has a County uh you know sentence jail
sentence some of them have state prison
sentences as well okay my last question
if I may um how many how many cases do
we expect this bill would would handle
per year you would create how many
veterans court cases will there be um
that we're not we're not 100% sure how
many there would be um I think that
there are other people here that might
be able to answer that better than I can
thank
you you need us Janet
problem seeing no further questions
much division like to move this
representative Sweeney you happy with
this represent mag so the two things we
talked about about making changes
here one was and and the main one that's
that's big time is um shall versus May
right um
because so that essentially can take the
money out of it right if we say to to um
counties that they may do such and such
than if they actually find it useful in
the sense that I just asked about you
know so that that it does save the money
because there' be fewer incarcerated
cases um then they can do it if and if
they so as I understand it this is
already being done in some counties but
not others and so if the experience in
those counties is positive they'll
they'll end up doing it but in addition
to that shall versus May um we were
thinking instead of just giving a
blanket $2 million a year for this for
this when we don't know how many cases
we don't know how much it's going to be
used why don't we say give um $5,000 a
case or some some particular number and
then that's a little incentive to do it
right we can say sha say may but here's
the little carrot that if you do these
cases we'll give you some money for them
and and um if that later doesn't work
out then maybe the the May later on
could become sha Etc but but at least
would be a way to get started and and
those counties that find it useful can
get going Etc so that's that's what I
had in
mind yeah because I'm looking at the
bill now and on page four line 33 it
does say may
obtain estate Grant um
well I'm looking at line three of page
one I mean the bill is a little confused
between what the Jud Judiciary what the
counties do and stuff like that I would
remind you that the policy committee
voted 18 to zero on this
sure but but again the reason for
changing the shall on line 3 page one
is I think to take the money out
right so are you going to offer an
amendment
or I I wanted to discuss it among us
first but I can
yes discussion represent wer I support
the concept and even um if if we say
shell then they're all going to go out
and panel a judge train him as necessary
and and set up a court and put out the
word that they have it and then sit
there for a year with no no case could
very well happen with as few cases as
we've heard I think initially there were
40 cases a year is what we heard which
some of the small counties would likely
be zero but they would have to spend the
money because we told them to to set up
a court it's a waste so I think this is
a better way to go about it and and even
have it so that the county has to do
some steps first and spend some of their
money before they come and ask us for
more and if they don't have the need
they won't spend the money thank you
represent Griffin I'm I'm fully in full
support of uh represent of McGuire's
proposed amendment I think it definitely
should leave it up to the counties
whether they want to do it or not and uh
the uh the state paying a modest
for a veteran that uses the court seems
like a reasonable approach so I'm in
full support of his proposed
amendment any further
comments seeing n representative evil
yeah I mean I think that sounds like a
really reasonable proposal um the only
question I would have is how we decide
the amount of money per case to give to
the county I representative mcgu
mentioned 5,000 I just didn't know how
that would be
calculated I guess every case is
different so it's hard to come down on a
specific
number represent brudi no no no all
right so you've got your marching orders
representative McGuire I guess we're
looking encouraging you to find an
amendment on this thanks I'll talk to
Mike so Mike will schedule this for next
Wednesday as
well is there any expert here that can
give us an idea about how much it might
cost
case oh I saw him moving I thought it
was toward this Podium but actually it
room so for the record Warren Perry
Deputy agent General New Hampshire
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services I would just say
represent mire did I did some analysis
and I think that reasonably based Bas on
per capita numbers by County I think the
total number per year you know based on
whatever analysis I did would be about
27 and that that really accounts for
just VA eligible veterans so there would
could be some nonv eligible veterans
that would be eligible under this the
way the statute's written so that number
could be as many as 60 a year but if we
got to 60 I would be very surprised I
think that I think the demand for it in
the veteran Court you know at least
initially would be certainly under 60 a
year but I think closer to about 27 a
year would be about where we would be
and then you know the caveat is you know
this the veteran population New
Hampshire is declining by about 2.8% a
year so the numbers that you hear a lot
of times 100,000 veterans right now
we're sitting at about 990,000 veterans
in the state three years from now it'll
be 86 so you know there'll be a unless
something changes there'll be a steady
decline in demand in the system just BAS
based on the number of veterans in the
state I hope that
helps may I uh ask my my co-presenter a
question is is there a difference in
cost if the person is not a VA veteran
that where VA is not going to shoulder
some of the costs yeah some some of the
some of the some of the costs associated
with the case management if they're if
they're eligible for VA Services is
shouldered by the VA counselors case
managers and some of those other things
nonv eligible veterans would be you know
that cost would be not shouldered by the
federal government so there would be
additional cost cost one another caveat
is the number of folks who are not VA
eligible based on some sort of
downgraded discharge from honorable is
relatively small so of those 990,000
veterans I would be really surprised if
there were 3,000 of them that had bad
paper right that had General discharge
or a bad conduct discharge it's really
rare but they might be the ones that
getting a little bit more trouble they
they could be the ones more apt to be
come in contact with the legal system
yes so yeah just as discussion so given
those kind of numbers that changes the
bill from a Millions per year to a
hundreds of thousand per year kind of
thing which I think is good for getting
started so with with the 5,000 number
that we talked about
so all right thank you very much so
we'll look forward to representative
Wednesday so we have have next uh Senate
Bill 252 I'm going to move that down to
um house to uh be in concert with House
Bill
318 they're merging those together so it
doesn't seem to make a lot of sense to
talk about 252 by
itself and it will bring us up to um
speed on U our
time
I believe we have a an amendment and
maybe in a new fiscal note I have a uh
revised fiscal note and representative
Maguire may have an
amendment yeah did you make it or
yes
so ask thank you so um so I'm opposed to
this bill in general for lots of reasons
and I can I can go into them um just to
just to give you an example I I brought
it some
stuff
um you know it this bill regulates
things like this right and so it it
assumes that that this might contain
pasas and and if the department thinks
it
does they will write a letter to the
president the whoever and somebody in
charge in the company saying does this
contain Pest and if so send us a letter
uh if not you have to you know if so
it's going to be banned but if not you
got to send us a letter saying saying
you attest that this doesn't contain
Pest and by contain the bill says it's
it's not the soda it's not the metal
it's the like the ink on the can or
maybe there's a spray on the inside of
the can that keeps the soda from
contacting the metal it's in there and
the bill says any amount right I mean if
if it just contains one of the compounds
that's on the list um and and it applies
to not this can just this but every item
in the grocery store every piece of
cloth every everything and and I don't
think such a regulatory
scheme can really so first of all
everybody knows that they're not going
to go after this guy right I mean that
would be ridiculous to to to think that
they could ban this even if there is p
in this ink I don't know but but the
point is they can go after anybody any
little you know uh
eel eel e ebener sorry Abel Ebenezer
Brewery in marac that makes beer and
sells it in
cans they could go after them right and
what are they going to do they don't
make the cans they don't make the ink
they're going to go to their supplier
and say can you give me the letter that
says I there's no Pas here and the
supplier's going to say well I don't
know you know uh and and they the lawyer
of the supplier is going to tell them
look you can't sign such a letter
because of you know you're going to put
yourself in in Jeopardy here and so Abel
Ebenezer is going to go out of business
Bud wires is not going to go out of
business cloaks not going to go out of
business cuz we're not going to get them
but but the little guys we're giving
Dees the opportunity to essentially put
every little guy out of business and let
me talk about something
else so this is a drug called
tastan okay it is not regulated by this
bill right so it's it's not drugs it's
only uh
grocery items and cloth and and
furniture and a few other things but but
this is
explicitly um not covered by the bill
and yet the
chemical that the bill says has to be
banned is in these
pills all right this is the number one
prescription drug in
America and it contains the chemical
that the bill
for bids okay so my Amendment and I I
let me hand this out by the way so
here's a you know a medical article that
explains all
that all right this is a I'll hand out a
few this way and a few this way all
right so um so this article goes into
the detail of nine different definitions
of Peep pass the one that we're using in
this bill
is the one if you go to uh let's go to
page
um the chart on
page whatever page
eight so the chart on page
eight this is this is um the one says
greater than or equal to one fully
fluorinated carbon okay so that's the
second column of of different
definitions so so it's these X's you see
that all drugs in this list contain this
is the number one prescription drug in
the in the world I well in the United
States I don't know about the world
called
Lipitor um it
contains it's it's in this greater than
equal to one column as well as all the
other drugs there so it includes proac
it includes I don't know there's a whole
bunch of drugs here um the amend mment
which
um is a different definition of pasas
and you know I got this from the the
span lobbyist okay so you know for
whatever that's worth
um moves our definition to the last
column in this chart so it's the US EPA
opt there's no X's there right so there
so it would
take it would um take the things
banned
um no longer includes the the stuff
that's in here right and so you know I
would argue that the number one
prescription drug in America has been
tested and is found to be safe or at
least you know usable uh because it's
used by some very high fraction of
people in the country and I would also
argue
that if you're swallowing the stuff
right it's going to
be very harmful to yourself compared to
if it's on the outside of your Coke can
or even on the inside of your Coke can
bound up in some thing or if it's in
your carpet or if it's in your T-shirt
or if you know all that kind of stuff
right if you're swallowing it that's got
to be the most harmful I would think but
you know not that I know but but anyway
so my Amendment moves us from the column
with all the
X's you know the stuff that's actually
in medication to the column that's not
in medication those will be the things
that would be
banned so I just want to again caution
my friend from Epsom that just came out
of the commer commission committee 16
to3 and we really have to try to focus
on the financial impact all right but is
it easier to regulate 15,000 compound
pounds or 1500 compounds that's the
issue
right so I mean all the
things if we if if by doing this we
exclude a large number of products that
need to be regulated then presumably it
costs less to regulate them but but the
costs are not just the cost to us right
I mean the the costs are the cost to
Society of seeing things that are useful
disappear from the
shelves that's all representative
wer I've been opposed to this since its
Inception I made calls when we were
working on the meramac uh New Hampshire
exposures and I called up Dees and I was
not satisfied with the answers I said we
can have 20 parts per million of arsenic
which is a deadly poison and 20 parts
per million are a safe level you're at
12 parts per trillion which is
infinitesimal compared with Arsenic and
you want it removed from all our water
when it's in the air it's in our carets
it's in our drapes it's in our clothing
and we didn't not have not to date have
any human testing to see what the effect
is I could be carrying 30 parts per
million of past from all the times I've
been exposed to it and it has had no
effect on it so until we see some I'd
say this is premature until we see some
human testing going on in meramac and
get the results to what is the
Toleration level the people that were
most affected one woman that had the
child with birth defects she was there
stirring up stuff in a in a
lab and and absorbing it I don't think
she was wearing any protective gear she
was exposed to this stuff while it was
being mixed and okay it had a pretty
Toxic effect on her and her her Sun but
that was total
overexposure and and and some of the
other people that were working in there
and where where their their Wastewater
got got dumped affected other people but
until we see the real results of the 2
and a half million we've we paid for
phase three testing in meramac I don't
think we have any idea and I'd be I'd
volunteer to be tested as how much P do
I have in my blood it's LEL to be far
more than 12 parts per trillion 10 years
ago you couldn't even measure that but
suddenly they can measure measure
minuscule amounts okay we're going to
have down to the minuscule amounts when
you don't even know the effects all of
this is is you know oh let's scare the
people and spend a lot of money and show
them the government's doing something
and it's bull thank
you so I've had some discussions with
representative Mooney from maram who
assures me this bill is absolutely
necessary and I'm certainly you know
representative Mooney has been closer to
it than probably any of us and I believe
she's even a co-sponsor of this
legislation and um knowing what she said
and you know what others have said but
anyway it's open for
discussion representative I'm sorry
representative
cells thank you Mr chair
um I agree kind of with both sides I
I think that more research is still
needed but uh in the from looking at it
from a financial standpoint I agree with
representative Maguire that it will be
easier to um regulate 1500 versus 15,000
so in the spirit of moving forward
because I do believe we need to do
something to start to mitigate Paces
being used in our products I would uh
entertain um representative Maguire's
Amendment and and that I think would
again from a financial standpoint would
mitigate the cost but also allow us to
move in a positive direction so I would
I would uh
support with the amendment but I
probably would not support without the
amendment all right the motion has been
made is it
seconded it's seconded by representative
Griffin uh that's 1227 now have some
discussion thank you very much um
and thank you for all the work and
thought that has gone into this um first
of all when we're changing the
definition this is a policy decision all
caps with glowing lights this issue of
whether or not to use this particular
definition was discussed in
Commerce and through a series Ser of
negotiations that involved span which is
the sustainable um Action pfast Network
and
Honeywell rather than change the
definition there is an exclusion in the
bill and it is on page four lines 6 to
10 and this
exclusion basically similarly tracks the
uh
definition that is being proposed by um
representative Maguire this was
discussed at length in the Commerce
Committee the lobbyists for many groups
were sitting there and when uh chair
hunt asked multiple times whether anyone
had any objection no one did this change
isn't going to really affect the cost of
implementation of the bill because the
exclusion basically tracks the
definition to some extent there are some
more uh compounds that would be included
with this Tusa definition that is being
proposed um and these additional
compounds I have discussed at length
with the state
toxicologist and he had concerns about
using this um
this definition which is why uh Commerce
decided to go with the exclusion and not
this
definition secondly this definition is
very complex you can see that it's a
series of chemical
equations this is not the definition
that is used by any state that has a ban
in place for products that's 22 states
it is also not the definition that is
currently used in the state of New
Hampshire with respect to firefighting
Pham so you're setting up a dichotomy
within our own statutes between
statute span you must understand is a
representative of past
manufacturers it is to their advantage
to have this definition because it's not
used any place else and if it's adopted
in the state of New Hampshire it can be
used to show that one state has gone
down this um track it's a complicating
change as much as I want this bill to
pass it's just a change that rips the
gut out of this bill now as far as the
expenses I mean
I think that you know obviously chair
Wilder you don't dis you don't agree
with the with the testing to a trillion
scientists have put that into place
where another way of looking at this
even if you don't look at it from the
health side of it you look at the cost
that we're that are having to uh we're
having to spend I mean it's already over
aund
million and these things these products
that are basically polluting our state
across the state from the soil
standpoint from the water standpoint
we're having to deal with them and it's
costing extreme amounts of money the
other thing I did email all of you
recently I don't have it in front of me
you have landfill operators you have
wastewater treatment plants I know in
Salem they just spent $6 million to
upgrade their wastewater treatment
plants the sooner or later the EPA is
going to come out with a requirement
that surface waters are tested before
they are released for pasas the pasas
that there it's probably going to be a
standard very similar to The Standard
that we currently have for drinking
water and it's going to C I can't even
guess I cannot even guess the amount of
money that that private um
municipalities are going to have to
spend on this and so this bill is a
vehicle to help our our
municipalities NH HMA also supports it
it'll help our landfill operators
because you heard they have a reverse
osmosis program at their landfill and
TurnKey that cost two or3 million and
they're spending
$50,000 a month to get the p and other
chemicals out of it TurnKey is the only
landfill that's treating its um leachate
before it sends it to a wastewater
treatment plant no other landfill is so
that means our our wastewater treatment
plants are having to deal with it and
honestly this is how I came to this
issue in the first place the solid waste
and the Wastewater people are very
nervous about future costs and then we
have the health care costs that we don't
so I have gone to so much
trouble to go through this bill to align
the things that are being banned with
what other states are doing so it makes
sense we're joining in we're not leading
off and not one of these products is
something that anybody can claim that we
need p in you don't need Pas on a
child's uh mattress you don't need p on
your lip in your
lipstick um I've talked
to there were people concerned about PPE
there were people concerned about
pesticides I removed the fluorinated
containers that would have contained uh
pesticides because I thought from a
safety standpoint I should do that the
drugs and the and the medic medal
devices that have been excluded are
because there is a preemption in in
thing with the federal Food and Drug
Administration and I do not want to get
in the middle or bring the state into
the middle of uh disagreements with uh
our Medical
Care this bill has been
excruciatingly reviewed and the list of
people who support it and want it passed
are a mile long
I
I and we're engaging here in a
discussion that is
100% um policy and we do have the new
the new fiscal note I mean I don't even
think that we've um that we've discussed
it but I I appreciate representative
camell that you want to come to an
agreement over this definition but from
a manufacturer
standpoint it's more complic ated for a
manufacturer to work within a ban with a
definition that doesn't go along with
anybody else's in this in the United
States than to use the definition that
everywhere represent Maguire thank you
well as I don't think that last
statement is correct because where this
definition comes from is an EPA document
which I think has something to do with
reporting it does I mean you're you're
so the EPA asks you to report using this
particular definition right because it
has made an agreement to exclude hfos
and hfos are what are excluded in my
exclusion but if you're a
manufacturer that is um dealing or or
complying with bands that go from
California to to uh
Colorado I told I mean I gave the chart
there's multiple states that are doing
this they're not they're going to be
doing some reporting through the EPA but
the banss apply with the definition that
I have here and that's why it's here I
mean that's why we discussed it at
length at the Commerce Committee that's
why they voted out of the committee 16
to3 we have been down this road and to
change up everything at this point is
basically disregard ing the com the
communications that we had in Commerce
it's like this is this couldn't be more
policy and honestly from a fiscal
standpoint uh it's not really going to
affect its
implementation it's putting our
manufacturers in a situation where they
have a different definition to deal with
with respect to the banss and Reporting
versus ban they're they're different um
and you're really harming the bill by
passing this definitional change and I I
won't be able to support it I can talk
some more about it but you probably I
mean if you want to talk about the
fiscal note we can representative s
followed by representative Griffin just
a question for you representative eel
and thank you for the work you put into
this you mentioned briefly a
conversation with the state
toxicologist about this definition can
you just go into further detail well I
mean this is the thing I probably spent
five hours with the man God bless him
and I went through every permutation
that you can think of of the chemistry I
talked to the fellow from span three or
four times I talked to the American
chemistry Council believe it or not they
have a model bill that is almost
identical to mine it has the same
products in it I mean you can ask jod
grimas we were on a conference call
three times with them I negotiated all
sorts of things with them so when I went
to the state talks echologist he had
concerns about using this definition um
in our bill because there were certain I
mean this gets into chemistry and where
you have double bonds and where you have
a carbon and where you have an oxygen
and he said that he thought that there
were toxology
concerns with this definition when it
came to bands and that's why I mean
believe me when I was sitting with span
I was like okay if we use this
definition will everybody be happy and
he basically said yes but then I went to
the toxicologist he didn't like it I
respect him he's a scientist and then I
talked to um all these other folks and I
looked at the bands and the and the
definition that was being used the other
thing is this is anti IP atory it can
look to the Future um and I gu I just
have to explain that this whole thing
with the definition and the exclusion
that I worked out it has to do with hfos
which are which are replacements for
hfc's which were the things in
refrigerants that were ozone
eaters and that's why you
know honey well in particular which
makes
refrigerants was particularly concerned
that this bill not apply to
hfos and I and even though there's not
one item in this bill that has hfos in
it I worked out a deal with them and I
put the exclusion in and that's why they
were fully on board with not changing
the definition the changes that I made
were reviewed by span and they approved
the um the exclusionary language and at
the end of the Commerce Committee
hearing I don't know how many times four
or five chair hunt and all these people
were sitting there said do you have a
problem with this and no one said a word
I've been told by a board member who's
on the policy committee and the
executive committee of the Bia that the
Bia is neutral we had absolutely nobody
here opposing it so if we make this ch
change we're making a change just
because there's some misgivings about
its applicability and it's not based on
all the support that's been developed
over the last four to six months all the
research that's gone into this it's like
we're just throwing it away and I it's
just really really uh Troublesome to me
I I so I really wish that you would
understand that the exclusion for the
most part takes care of what's happening
with this definitional change um I
removed the notification Provisions
because they were a problem for
manufacturers and I didn't see them
anywhere else in the country I took the
labeling Parts out they were a problem
for manufacturers I saw them nowhere
else in the country this bill has been
refined and cut back and refined and cut
back and that's why when we get to
finance we don't deal with policy in all
caps because the policy has been worked
on so much before we even got here and I
would not bring a bill to you that I
didn't think worked for New Hampshire
and was leading us down the Primrose
path I'm really concerned about the um
about the health of our people and about
the cost that we have ahead of us so
thank you I that's a very long answer to
your question but yes the toxicologist
had conc concerns with this
definition representative Griffin I have
a very simple question uh the definition
here every item in that definition is
covered by your definition is it not
every item that's in this definition is
covered by my definition in other words
this is a subcategory of your definition
it's a it's a subcategory of it that
in so we're doing good with sticking
with the definition that we have again
it's the one that's used across the
United States for these sorts of bands
and it's the one that's in the
firefighting foam um statute so if we
change it we're actually in some ways
maybe messing around with what we
already have in
law and it's a I mean you can see it
it's a very complicated um chem set of
chemical equations that's why nobody
uses it it's very difficult to apply so
if we want to do something really good
for the state and and like we did with
Mercury because there's a Clearing House
for mercury we did for toxics and
packaging because there's a clearing
house for that we would apply this in
the same way this is just another um
chemical and if this bill is
changed the supporters I can tell you
will be extremely disappointed because
they they stayed so long and have worked
bill seeing no further questions we do
have an amendment on the floor that was
offered by representative Maguire it was
moved by representative cambrell
seconded by representative Griffin it's
12278 and when the clerk is ready take
please
right okay moved by Maguire seconded by
guess
cells
representative
wer uh representative Maguire yes
Griffin yes representative Sweeney no
representative
cambrell
yes clerk votes uh nay representative
barudi no representative grassy no
representative or chair
leean
no okay so the amendment fails one two
[Music]
three yes I did but I don't um okay I
don't know if people have it in front of
them
number Mr Hoffman Mr Hoffman's going to
everyone um I'll show you where it is
just
could I respond just briefly to
represent uh chair Wilder's comment I
thought you asked the question um when
Nancy Murphy was here the last time
whether they now have human studies that
have shown cancer and she said they did
but I know that we have another kidney
cancer cluster um thing but I just think
that and then Nancy just wrote us some
followup information about um human
testing but you know I I guess I would
also say this is about more than cancer
it's about endocrine um Interruption and
all many other health effects and not
just
cancer okay and I'll second it oh you'll
second
it okay there's been a an amendment
offered 1086
6h it's been moved by representative
Griffin I'm sorry grassy seconded by
representative Griffin when the clerk is
ready please call the role
okay could I just speak very briefly to
the amendment all all I was going to all
to be said is that if you with the
removal of the uh notification and all
the other provisos the reason that the
that the uh bill was originally
effective in 2020 was all this
preliminary stuff that's been removed
and um and I've spoken to the agency I I
have to say I I heard from um Mr whims
that his father just had a very bad fall
and he's not able to be here otherwise
he could corroborate this he said that
from an agency standpoint um moving up
the date didn't really affect anything
one way or the other so okay
representative
Wier uh representative Maguire no
Griffin representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes clerk votes
yes uh representative barudi yes
representative grassy yes and
representative leean yes okay so the
amendment passes um 9
to1
sorry are there any further amendments
to
um
1649 yeah I I haven't I haven't even
seen the fiscal note but I guess I would
ask Mr Hoffman and Melissa um when I
spoke to um Mr whimet he said that the
way this was
written the money
lapses uh within a certain bium and if
the ban takes place outside the time
period of the
bium um the money would be
gone and he wondered if we should say
non-aps I'm sorry with so much going on
I haven't actually looked at this he
said in so I guess it would be in um
of section three page six he just wanted
to make sure if the money was
appropriated that it could continue to
be used by the department as it as the
out I think it was I'm not sure if
there's a problem with that uh if if you
don't think it's a he thought
one well or I just want to make sure
okay seeing no further amendments on
1649 would someone like to offer a
motion to move this along to full
committee I'd love to move this uh to
pass as amended Mr chair thank you very
much for the opportunity and I I just
want to thank my fellow division members
um for listening and for all the work
that we've put into it awesome thank you
and it's seconded by representative
Sweeney when the clerk is ready please
okay okay chair Wier
no Griffin
no Maguire CH representative Maguire no
representative Griffin no representative
Sweeney yes Representative camell
no clerk votes yes uh representative
barudi
yes representative grassie yes chair
Lehman yes so it passes uh 5 to
four
all right this this will be taken up by
week so we do have next as we was noted
we move Senate Bill 252 to be taken up
with the house bill
318 um there is an amendment to
consolidate Senate Bill 252 Senate Bill
249 and House Bill 318
that Mr Hoffman will pass out um there's
a lot to all this and being that it's 10
minutes at 12 and we have we'll schedule
this for a full discussion for next
Wednesday or Tuesday whatever it works
in but uh if you
recall there were a lot of uh issues
between lining fiscal notes up and some
overlap with some of the
bills so what working with
Mr Hoffman and
Melissa we put everything together into
one bill there no language change of any
of the bills but it's all one bill with
a updated fiscal note I have U reached
out to the ranking member of the
criminal justice committee and the chair
I've not heard back from Terry Roy the
chair the reason for you know I want to
hear from Terry as well the judicial
branch has looked over this and I have
heard from eron that they saw no no
problems but again there's a lot to it
Mr Hoffman is also put together a
comparison uh comparing each bill and
where the language went into the new
house bill 318 which he'll hand out for
weekend so once uh thata all that
um does this include the training U
issues that we deferred to this
committee yesterday it does not so
that's got to be added in it will
probably be added in because there is
some overlap there um as you'll see in
this new combined Amendment the bill
commissioner fee is now $60 that
Amendment we saw yesterday was 50 but um
I'm going to be talking to
representative Maguire to see how we can
try to roll 10:05 into this as well 105
has been scheduled for next week as well
excellent thank you it actually still
say Mr chair Mr Hoffman if I can explain
this a little bit
sure this takes the
three this takes the three uh bail
reform bills 249 252 and House Bill 318
and combines them into one that's all it
does is string them
together uh the the large sheet that I
handed out is in the same ORD of the
three bills and it kind of shows you in
the right hand column where there may be
overlap or things to considering other
bills and then at the bottom put a
little box in there that says decisions
to be made so hopefully at the end of
the process you go through this and
you'll have a document that hits all the
issues but doesn't duplicate or conflict
with within the
bills you know and we do have an
amendment I know you prepared one for
the $60 it's separate I have separate
amendments that members have asked for
for 252 and 318 and as those are
together I I did note and representative
Maguire noted as well that some of the
numbers are still different I know the
judicial branch gave us some new numbers
as far as the costs which were lower
than what the original bills had for
fiscal notes that's correct would you
like the other amendments handed out
please
e
I want to make sure we hear from uh
chairman Roy as well and I see the
ranking member is here and she's been oh
she's
gone
Amud no
agree as a chair probably recalls the
Senate move the fee up to $60 that would
support
so for after lunch I guess we got a
number of cannabis amendments coming
forward representative Maguire you have
one right um no I well yes I have an
amendment I I just asked for Senator
ab's uh amendment to be formally graphic
um but I have other thoughts about can
us that you know we really need a big
picture look at it rather
than you know getting into the weeds typ
of
weed although representative McGuire
goes below the weeds
right yeah I was just in yeah I was just
in Maine and and there's like one
there's a store every street corner I
mean it's just
incredible what it's like over there but
but
um you know the so there the there's a
lot of things we we let's talk about it
at 1:00 I
guess no
yeah
yeah no I I've actually never used it so
worth
so obviously we don't have to take up
any of these amendments but if you want
to put them together with
the document that you have with the
comparisons we can take them all up next
week yeah there was another bill that
we're no longer in custody of that had
magistrates correct that's one of the
Senate bills it's one put it in here
yeah it's in there there we the f note
was really confusing So In fairness to
the chair when he looked at it there was
no yeah there was no impact but there
really was buried in the bill but it was
way back to the Senate but there was a
large amount of money but it wasn't
listed it was kind of tucked in the bill
helpful and if if I think what we can do
sorry I think what we can do in this
case is if we make sure that the
effective date of this bill is like a
day after whatever the effective date of
that bill was
then then this would replace it right
about Janet is uh putting them down as
we
speak so it looks like
Tuesday Tuesday or Wednesday she said it
was depending on when you planned uh
full
Finance yeah was either going to be when
that we wouldn't want to have you miss
chairman Mr chair one more thing we we
have house bill
one5 from
yesterday and that'll kind of it's not
in the uh the walkth through but it'll
parts you just want to add that in for
next week as far as fitting it into the
comparison for this yeah yeah I can do
that thank
you all right we'll be back here at 1
you
e
so we'll open the work session on um
house bills
1633 relative to the legalization and
regulation of cannabis and making an
appropriation
therefore like to call a prime sponsor I
believe you have maybe an updated
Amendment right and some other
information for
us regrets to the committee from
representative grassy he broke off of
his yeah and I'm not sure where he's
yeah um thank you I last week I came in
with a marked up which was the
information that I had presented to OS
um I have now have the official
Amendment because it took so long to do
that pivoting to a replace all was time
prohibit of because I wasn't even sure
if they'd get it to me in time for this
hearing um so because of that I had also
provided the original Bill where I went
through in the PDF and I marked out
anything that is amended is grade out
and anything that is struck is struck
out just so that it's easier to compare
and I apologize that just because of
time constraints changing to a replace
all just wasn't really a feasible ask so
my apologies there
so getting sorry no not at all now is
the fiscal note has that been updated
for this do you know Mr
Hoffman um so as far as a fiscal note
there was an addition for the Department
of Health and Human Services um with Mr
Hol and that is included in here um any
additional updates that that are part of
this process in order to better
understand exactly what the Liquor
Commission needs in order to start this
up um I'd be happy to figure out how to
do that and sorry I'm sort of putting my
parachute on on my way out of the plane
trying to figure out how to make sure
that we have the right
Appropriations but I'm just going to
grab on to one of you guys because you
have a parachute and it'll be able to
us no it's very helpful have the clean
and the markup that that's very helpful
okay thank you um and so just zooming
back out now it's been said that this
model is just a rebranding and a
redressing of the the free market model
and that it's the same thing as other
states but that's not actually true in
other states there's a cannabis
commission but that is not so deeply
embedded in the government as our Liquor
Commission is most of those are at arms
length and most of those are reporting
through a whole bunch of different lay
layers in order to protect the state
from involvement they don't have the
same kind of control that our Liquor
Commission does in liquor and this truly
is an agency model where we're looking
at that control through agency as
opposed to control through state run
stores or this new idea of franchise
stores so this this is not what's going
on in other states I also want to let
you know that in other states there are
not um franchise Outlets any franchises
or for different things like different
brands like cookie it's one of the
brands that's sold all around the
country but because you can't sell
Interstate they license the the products
they license the seed and then people
within the different states do them so
generally when you hear the term
cannabis franchise that's talking about
the product level and not the regulatory
scheme so um getting back to this
amendment and to this bill it has been
narrowed to be just a hard 15 stores
just as was seen in the other competing
Amendment um because the idea is we need
to start out small this requires the
Secretary of State to come up with the
rules around the um lack of lobbying and
political contributions that are part of
that that recipe that's necessary for
our cake to actually make it out of the
oven um and this bill really has a lot
of solid positive control over the
market the state controls advertising
and marketing in this by having very
very tight rules on what is allowed in
products and product categories that was
already existing in the bill um where
you can't have something that looks like
it has cartoon characters or something
that depicts misuse of cannabis you
can't have the bloodshot eyes behind the
wheel um that's not acceptable and
definitely not acceptable in our classy
cannabis model um and by not advertising
we're not bringing new people into using
cannabis I recognize that there's an
interest in spending the tax dollars
that come from Cannabis uh my husband's
Mentor um C ever coup the former s
Surgeon General said there's nothing so
addictive as is spending tax dollars
from cigarettes and that's something
where we want to make sure that we are
balancing those two different needs the
need to make sure that people who are
already using cannabis aren't buying
contaminated products or simply uh
putting money into coffers of other
states versus growing the market here
and having the state involved in
increasing the number of cannabis
users so over time it does seem that
there is a trend um to more people as
there's some understanding there are
some people who are becoming lowd does
users people who use Edibles or
tinctures or something else where they
know sort of what they're getting if
they want to have some sort of
controllable um some controllable High
you know somebody like having a beer as
opposed to somebody going for some ever
CLE um you know you you have the the
different ways that people can
experience things and by moving it off
of the streets into a regulated market
those people who do want to have
essentially half a beer in the Cannabis
would be able to do
that um as far as appr Appropriations um
this bill has uh money for the positions
that are needed at the Department of
Health and Human Services for the
recordkeeping um there's a lot of data
information that was initially given to
the Department of Information Services
that is not part of what they do that
actually is appropriately housed in the
Department of Health and Human Services
and with Mr Holt from the Department we
were able to amend that language it's
already in there this amendment now has
the funding that's necessary for
it so um I guess I'm I'm not not sure
exactly which questions you have about
this I think that this is a really
really solid model that allows positive
State control over a market to make sure
that it doesn't grow too quickly but
also make sure that it has the
flexibility necessary so that we can
have um The Innovation
within a controlled framework so that
people will want to come to New
Hampshire um either stay in New
Hampshire and purchase the Cannabis
they're already buying out of state here
or for tourists when they're coming
through that perhaps along with some
maple syrup they might also pick up um
state willing to take questions I am
representative Maguire thank you Mr
chairman so thank you representative for
coming so let's uh talk about money here
33 um of the original Bill no as amended
by the house this one that marked up
thing yes sorry okay so let's start at
the top of the page $100,000 annually
Department of Health and Human Services
for data collection and reporting of the
health impacts of of this um how did the
$100,000 come about um thank you that
came from the Department of Health and
Human Services estimating that cost is
$100,000 is there an employee in
involved um I'm not sure if Mr Holt is
here but if we look on the amendment
there okay somebody can talk about this
you want to welcome I'll slide to this
easier if you could just state your name
for the record please uh certainly thank
you everybody my name is Michael Holt
I'm the administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program within the Department
of Health and Human Services thanks for
uh having me um the bill as introduced
established the responsibility for data
collection um and reporting of Baseline
data and uh changes to that Baseline
data relative to health outcomes to the
to another agency that agency came to
the public hearing at Commerce and said
we don't have the resources we don't
have the staff and
HHS has most of the data so the amend
the amendment um or the the bill in
front of you um that came out of
Commerce has the Department of Health
and Human Services taking over this this
responsibility um and in the amendment
that representative Lon has proposed um
has the accurate number of uh has the
appropriation um and the the staff
creation um language so we need a staff
person to do this
work and we need an appropriate ation
for that work to pay for that staff
person and the amendment that you have
in front of you has that language in
section 30 um on page
15 in addition the Department of Health
and Human Services is responsible for
the
administration of a fund created by this
bill it's called the substance use
prevention treatment and Recovery Fund
uh and we are required to do rules for
the uh um the dispersement of that
fund it requires reporting um for how
that fund is uh being
dispersed again representative lean's
amendment
has specific language that creates a new
position for that responsibility and an
position yeah thank you so um are you
not doing already this kind of reporting
stuff for the for the medical
program uh we we are doing an annual
data report for the medical program yes
but this is unrelated uh this is an
unrelated
function okay all right the types of uh
the types of uh uh of data that would be
required to be reported by this are
Baseline data with regard to um DUI
convictions um um the original Bill had
uh graduation rates um things like uh
unintentional childhood poisonings um
and these are not these are not things
that the medical program is uh is is
tracking um in our annual data report
what we do is number of patients you
know number of providers uh some really
basic data uhu but not impacts of Health
outcomes at large to the general
population of New Hampshire okay all
right let's go on to the substance abuse
thing that you mentioned
um does this creates a brand new fund
Etc we already have a drug and alcohol
treatment fund right um is there some
reason why we couldn't just put more
money into it or as opposed to creating
a whole new thing um I'm not the drafter
of this section um my understand and and
unfortunately my uh colleague from the
Bureau of drug and alcohol Services is
not able to be here today however my
understanding is that the desire uh or
the intent of a separate fund is to
ensure that this funding remains for its
intended purpose um we have historical
examples of the uh the money dedicated
from the liquor money going to this fund
being reappropriated and reallocated in
different directions so the idea behind
this is to um my understanding is to
keep it separate to keep it safe for its
dedicated purpose um you'll note however
the language in this bill does require
this fund Administration to be in
concert with the governor's Commission
on Alcohol and Other Drugs um principles
and um and
priorities um so it is a separate fund
could it be joined with the existing
fund probably um but the desire here as
the the initial drafters were to keep it
separate to keep it
safe um and to add add one other point
to that in the other fund that's
pre-existing that one is moving to a
large focus on harm reduction harm
reduction is mitigating all the
non-legal consequences of using an
illegal product um taking cannabis which
now would be no longer prohibited in the
state and using that to address the
consequences of illegal drug use as
opposed to dealing with the with any
potential consequences around somebody
who's experiencing cannabis misuse would
be moving it from a addressing anything
related to passage of this bill and
moving it into a different area and
because if you're dealing with those
other issues and the harm reduction
we've talked about things like
potentially addressing housing as a harm
reduction issue uh I recognize that
there's a lot of factors that go into it
but this is trying to keep it more
focused on the proximate C proximate
issues of cannabis but but existing I
mean drug and alcohol right one is legal
one isn't right so already that fund
deals with some people who are having
problems with a legal product and some
people having problems with an illegal
product that's a true statement I missed
that part okay all right so um all right
now my current understanding is that
number one to some extent uh cannabis is
a substitute for for alcohol right that
there's going to be some people that are
currently alcohol users who will will
who will use less and use more cannabis
does that sound right I know quite a few
people in other states that no longer
drink okay um do we have any concept of
what fraction that will be or something
like that um I think that's a hard thing
to put a number on people talk about the
use of cannabis increasing on
legalization but I really think a lot of
that is a reporting issue that once it's
no longer prohibited more people are
willing to say that they use a product
so there's people who would just lie or
not mention the fact that they used
cannabis previously so it's hard to have
good self-reported data on something
that had been illegal well I may ask the
Liquor Commission about how have sales
to outof State residents changed since
they have legalized marijuana all right
the second question is my current
understanding is that that cannabis is
less harmful than
alcohol that that fewer PE I I read an
article which compared The Addictive
qualities of
nicotine uh cannabis cocaine and alcohol
okay and it said nicotine
67%
addictive um alcohol 23% addictive
cocaine 20% addictive and cannabis 9%
addictive
okay so less than half compared to
alcohol
so so to the extent that people use
cannabis instead of alcohol aren't the
problems less and therefore we need less
of this kind of uh treatment and those
kind of things um so I think that also
leaves out the fact that physical
dependency is an physical addiction um
chemical addiction is not something that
happens with cannabis so with alcohol
one of the reasons why we kept the
liquor stores open when everything else
was locked down is that people can die
if they suddenly can no longer consume
alcohol I have a friend who had a major
heart attack he was smoking two packs a
day he can't go cold turkey because that
could kill him because of the physical
addiction issues so um yes I think that
the harms could be a lot less but I
think that there's a lot of concerns out
there and a lot of lack of understanding
just because this is something that's
been sort of hidden in the shadows for
so long that I think that starting off
with a fund that would deal with any of
these problems is a good way to address
it because if you have if you have more
people who you know I think that maybe
priming the pump and potentially putting
a little bit more into this to start
makes sense if we find that we're
finding lower harms now that cannabis
once cannabis is legal then we can move
that out and we can do something with it
and that's probably what we will see but
let's wait until we see what the facts
bear out before we move this away and
see if we can see what it actually cost
to treat anything related to cannabis
because if we find that these funds
pretty much go unuse because they were
not seeing actual problems from Cannabis
misuse that would be subject to these
funds then that would go a long way even
beyond the data that would be collected
if we literally have no place to spend
the money to address these substance use
disorder um in cannabis then that shows
us that it was a lot safer than some
people had been concerned with so I'd
have if we keep it like this and then
change it in the future because it's
less harmful I'd say that's a win for
everybody if I if I may I might just
offer the uh one of the purposes for
this fund um and and one of the uh is
for public education campaigns both
preliminary before uh retail sales
happen and um during uh the the roll out
and afterwards so the uh the public this
is a homark of other success successful
programs where these public education
campaigns need to be well funded um for
the start of uh retail sales um and
continue thereafter thank you yeah um
all right I I don't have any other HHS
related questions but I do have more on
this page so if anybody else I'll be
right out there if you need me well
maybe somebody else thanks for coming I
if you could sit
down H sit down uh thanks for coming
could you explain in the in this new
Amendment how atc's are handled for
I mean she but and if you want to
comment on the ATC program and its
success and its treatment under these
bills the Department's General position
would be any any model of adult use
legalization needs to take into
consideration um the therapeutic
cannabis program which has been
operational with the law in place for 10
years and and fully operational for the
past seven uh we have 14,000 patients um
being served by the ther utic cannabis
program and it is a valuable
program and a and a path of either
transition or integration with an adult
important my belief or my understanding
of both the bill that has come out of
Commerce and the
amendment creates if not a perfectly
clear path for transition and
integration
it does create a path for integration
and transition some of those Hallmarks
um
include uh include a requirement for the
Department of Health and Human Services
to work collaboratively with the Liquor
Commission
o by December 1st 2024 to come up with a
legislative plan for next session on how
to integrate these two programs the
language states that uh the the plan
must be uh must consider transitioning
the therapeutic cannabis program in
whole or in part and so we would be
working you know when this if this bill
passes we' be working with the Liquor
Commission closely um to figure out does
for instance HHS keep the patient
registry and continue uh issuing cards
um do we send over or propos to send
over the regulation of the atcs the
licensing aspect of the the cultivators
and the retailers uh to The Liquor
Commission or do we move the whole thing
over to the Liquor Commission Now
obviously you know that the Liquor
Commission may not be um uh Adept yet at
a public health related program of of
patient you know Registries but there
may be a value in maintaining the
Integrity the program at a whole as a
whole so that that is the Hallmark in my
mind of what uh representative this bill
and the Amendments support and that is
an acknowledgement that a transition
plan and an integration plan
must be considered as we move
forward there are other detailed
Provisions in here about um uh requiring
The Liquor Commission
to have
a I mean you might be able to speak uh I
can hop in now WR um and so within this
um we had in Commerce one of the last
changes is we had removed the Dual use
lure because that was something that had
a lot of different objections
I I didn't see all of the conflict about
the idea of having two masters because
you can have somebody who has two
different regulations um because if
you're selling food and you're selling
alcohol you're dealing with the
Department of Agriculture and you're
dealing with the Liquor Commission um
however it did seem more straightforward
to get rid of that dual use lure um we
had included that one of the major
criterias in assessing the relative
merits of applications would be a
successful operation as a ATC so that
that would recognize what the atcs have
already done and consider that in the
process that is in the bill it's um it's
it's in the section that was amended um
even though those were there page eight
of the amendment lines 9 through 12 what
I did not catch when I removed the Dual
use and which is probably the most
important thing about this amendment is
that I had not had anything about making
sure that they were issued a cultivation
license um and they were still able to
cultivate the therapeutic cannabis and
that they would be able to cultivate
both adult use and therapeutic cannabis
at the same facility that they would not
have to move their facility that they've
already established and have already had
approved through Municipal regulations
um to a different location just because
now that we're adult entering the adult
use people may have changed their
perceptions about what should happen
where um from what I know about all the
locations where it's cultivated for
therapeutic use those have all been
placed in places where they're sort of
out of the way and not really a problem
for people in the communities and um
sort of having to reopen that and deal
with that especially if a town doesn't
want to have adult use but they're fine
continuing with the therapeutic let's
let's not mess with what we have and so
that's one of the significant parts of
this amendment so you'd find at the
bottom of page eight lines 35 through 37
that's on the cultivation on page 10 the
restrictions of locations and
grandfathering is lines 17 through 20 um
and I have a feeling there's another one
that I didn't see just flipping through
I apologize I had had that road map that
I laid out with that highlighted yellow
one last week but I didn't bring that
with me sorry I should have brought a
file
cabinet may I would also offer that um I
believe the this committee has received
um handouts from um one of the atc's
Granite Leaf cannabis um that has a
crosswalk between the highlights of the
the 1633 um and this amendment alongside
um the Senator's uh Amendment as well um
showing the differences in in in and how
1633 does create um a a a path towards
integration and and considers the the
the fate of the um therapeutic cannabis
program um and I'm I'm sure Mr Simon
will be happy to detail those uh as as
as well um we know we know that when
states legalize for adult use the
patient registration roles in a medical
program drop dramatically we have 14,000
patients in the program a a 30 to 50%
drop Is Not Unusual um and the the the
basic problem is that if half the
patients no longer are serving uh or no
longer being served by the atcs it
becomes a question of how long will they
be able to remain viable serving a
severely diminished population patient
population base if they're not uh if
they're not granted a path into the uh
the adult use space and I think this
Bill
creates that path to a to a certain
degree it's as it's as good as we're
going to get at this
point and and with that it's more that I
could get a prescription for a 600
milligram Ibuprofen but I can also go to
the count to go to the drugstore and
have my over-the counter 200 milligram
pills too that's there's some where
there's a reasonable substitution where
somebody would have that access so is
that is that a good understanding of why
people drop off um yeah that is a good
uh the vast majority of people who use
cannabis are in some part using cannabis
to self-medicate a a self a medical
condition um and if you don't have to go
to the state and pay them $50 and go to
your doctor to talk about you know your
self-medication people will choose the
easy path um and choose the the
recreational store not register for the
program however there's a segments of
the population the therapeutic cannabis
population which which need a medical
program in order to participate um
people who would never think especially
an older population they would never
think to go into a recreational retail
store where the goal is to purchase the
highest potency THC product possible um
because that's all they see uh without
getting without without having talk to
their doctor first without going to a
place that has education and staff that
is aligned with a therapeutic use and so
those are the patients they don't make
up the majority of the 14,000 but they
are critical people to be able to
continue to serve um within the
program further
question thank you Mr chairman um is the
14,000 the ones with current
prescriptions or is it the total number
of the over the history of the program
that have had a prescription no it's the
current number um and and it's important
they're not prescriptions technically I
know it's you know it's it's words but
you know they matter there's
certifications providers certify that a
patient has a qualifying condition which
allows them to be on the program to
purchase cannabis providers in New
Hampshire are not prescribing cannabis
they can't prescribe cannabis due to its
Federal
prohibition does the certification
expire at some point um yes currently
the certifications are good for up to
three years at a time the default is one
year um the legislature passed uh um
passed a law allowing certifying
providers based on their clinical
discretion to certify for up to three
years at a time and then they have to
renew so if if someone took it for six
months and their medical problem got
cured you wouldn't necessarily know
about it they would still be on your
list as one of the one of the active
ones I
in in theory but I would that the vast
majority of the qualifying conditions
that are authorized by the legislature
are chronic in nature um and and
cannabis is not Curative it is a way to
alleviate symptoms so no one is no one
is being cured of their Ms through the
use of cannabis they are Ma they're
they're managing their symptoms through
through its use uh we do have Provisions
in our rules that says that you know um
a provider is required to void or not
renew a person card if they no longer
suffer from that particular condition um
and that happens or somebody tries it
for their Condition it's not effective
and then they stop using it absolutely
and we have a process where people um uh
can and do um self void their cards they
submit a a request to to void their
cards happens regularly thank you and
one of the things that was just recently
p is we had um we changed the rules
around chronic and severe pain so when I
was a medical device analyst one of the
big things when you're getting a hip
replacement or a knee replacement is
being able to move quickly so opioids
have always been a part of that
previously our law required you to try
opioids but there is the potential for
somebody if all they need is enough so
that they're not grimacing and pain when
they're walking on that new joint that
if that is something where the doctor
thinks it's appropriate to certify that
would be a short-term use but that's
because it's something where otherwise
there would be short-term opioids but
that's pretty much the only unique
short-term use that we have that I know
that's right and our forms allow a
three-month certification or a six-month
trial
say are any more questions for
Mike I do have a quick one it's kind of
going off the reservation a little bit
when you went into medical marijuana H
there were uh how many stores initially
and were a few more added as years went
on
or yes when the law first passed in 2013
it allowed uh and still allows for a
maximum of four ATC alternative
treatment center licenses each one of
those licenses required The Entity to be
not for profit and also vertically
integrated vertically integrated means
that they were each entity was required
to cultivate manufacture and dispense
therapeutic
cannabis they were only allowed under
the original uh legislation to have one
retail location for dispensing so for
years there were four stores in the
entire State um in 2018 and 2019 I
believe legislation passed to allow each
one of the lenses to open a second
dispensary location within their region
um and to date three out of the four
lenses uh have have opened um a second
location so we have seven locations
right now but that is capped there's you
know we would need a law change to allow
them to open you know additional
locations um I would say that you know
we we do uh needs and assessments and
you know in terms of you know travel
time and whatnot and the North country
is significantly you know has a
significant travel burden with regard to
uh to to accessing the most northern
location at Conway now a number of
states have gone from the medical to
retail sales of facilities is was that
ever explored with you folks doing that
that option has been explored by the
legislature for years you know um and
and it's a it's a standard approach with
regard to other states allowing dual use
licenses um allow or and and even you
know
grandfathering uh medical entities into
the adult youth space um the Vermont
model is instructive if you know the
it's a very similar program where
there's very few U Medical dispensaries
and those dispensaries when they passed
an adult use law um as long as they met
the requirements had a license in good
standing as a medical facility they were
granted um uh the ability to serve adult
use patients so you know the department
is not you know Department's neutral on
legalization um we are interested in a
path forward that maintains the
viability of these atcs and maintains
their ability to continue to serve the
patients of New
Hampshire thanks Mike as always your
testimony is very
helpful thank you I I have a couple
questions but anybody else in the
division and just to address that last
point the our legislation initially had
allowed all of the atcs to convert and
be able to sell adult use as well um but
under the 15 store cap um that's why
it's more giving them an an extra little
Factor within the consideration because
when you have 15 stores there were a lot
of people that were concerned that it
wouldn't be fair to automatically give
them a license um I think that they've
been in the market for quite some time
and I think that they've uh they've been
able to provide that access so I
wouldn't be opposed to that but it's not
all about exactly what one person wants
it's about the one that gets to the
necessary all right well I do have a
couple of financial questions I see as
far as the Appropriations on your new
page 15 thank you going on to 16 we've
got the
uh $8 million for uh the fiscal year
ending in 25 so there's been no change
there that would come out of as you're
proposing General
funds and then down on line 18 whereas
before we didn't know where that money
was coming from that was now looks like
it's coming out of General funds so I
guess my question is we've heard a lot
of different numbers flying around from
other proposals is the8 and a half or
8.6 million I guess because there's some
money there for the Department of Health
and Human Services is that sufficient
and I'm looking back at the commissioner
of
it I think I saw a figure of about 500
mill I'm sorry five million dollars
there just to take care of the upgrades
necessary at The Liquor Commission as
you probably know this been some
longstanding problems with this nextg
system over there inventory issues
control so is that enough to take care
of bringing the Liquor Commission online
to do this through upgrades and it so I
commissioner if you'd like to come
forward and maybe address that because I
do see that there is a figure here that
I don't know if you provided that number
in the fiscal node or where that came
from well uh good afternoon Mr chair
members of the committee uh Dennis goule
the uh commissioner of the Department of
Information Technology um I maintain a
close relationship with the chairman and
his leadership team so we we speak about
it issues uh on a regular basis um and
particularly on the ne nextg project
which you referred to um so um the
intent here would be to um uh Implement
a separate set of systems for this
business so that we're not comingling
the lior and cannabis data so that would
involve licensing as well as the um you
know managing the product life cycle of
of the product so that so that liquor is
able to fulfill their regulatory role um
so you know the good news is the bad
news is it's something new we haven't
done before so I'm sure there'll be
challenges there the good news is that
implementing you know Green Field new
systems without having to replace
something else is orders of magnitude
more simple uh to do than changing out a
a complex system that's already running
in a complex business so I I'm confident
that you know we we collaborated on
those numbers and I'm confident that
we're you know we're not exact but we're
within an order of
magnitude now what do you anticipate as
far as getting the system up and running
and being able to fully function like
two years one year what's your best shot
as far as an estimate um I'm not sure I
could answer that I think that um as we
get into the process of if should this
pass and should we get moving on getting
the business up and running then we'll
be doing the procurements and the
procurements will help educate us on
what the time frame I would I'm just a
you know educated guest I'd say between
range
I don't have any further questions of
the commission or anybody else uh
representative eil you thank you for
coming um so just could you talk a
little bit about as far as it costs
isn't it true that to the extent our
systems is similar to others it'll be
less expensive to develop our it and if
it's completely different it's more and
how does that affect the
cost well it is true that systems where
we where um
requirements uh compliance with um
complex requirements inside um federal
or state statute um can drive complexity
which also drives cost and then changing
it frequently also drives cost right so
if we end up having a you know we
Implement something and four years later
we you know we create a whole set a
different set of requirements or
increasing requirements and that drives
complexity which drives um both upfront
cost in terms of implementing it into
the systems as well as maintaining it on
an ongoing
basis um there are vendors out there who
are are in this business already
um you know if I'm thinking that if our
model ends up being close to one of
those we may be able to go right out of
the box with one of those
systems um if not but you know I'm not
saying that to influence what what is
passed but rather just you know a
statement of what I think will
happen further questions of the
commissioner sing now I really
appreciate your being here sir all right
thank you thanks and so I guess I'll ask
him after if that means the same sort of
uh traceability issues and that sort of
thing so that we can figure out what
what to align best but I'll I'll catch
you afterwards on that and I'll tell you
guys so I see in the new version uh I
didn't happen to find the breakdown of
where the funds were going in the
original version you had like 65% going
here and then another 5% going there I
didn't see that in the new draft have
you taken that out on page 33 no that's
still within there in the dra okay
because I would looking at you're marked
up page 33 but I'm looking at the
corrected one so I see it's still there
but this is this is an amendment to the
original
Bill well this is the one we got today
that was the mark so we have um so I had
had that yellow one previously but this
one that I had emailed you last night
that has the grade out areas it just
Grays out the areas that have been
amended so that anything that's not is
is remaining okay I'm cuz I saw the
second one here the 15 page document I
thought you would scale this 37 page
document down to 15 so I apologize for
that that would be nice hopeful you know
I was hopeful I I would love that lower
regulatory touch but that's not
something that the state is ready for at
this point and um quite honestly it
probably may not be because it is a
complex
topic now the representative uh from Dar
knows I've asked the ncsl to do a deep
dive in this whole situation and I we'll
have that information for our next
meeting so I'm already learning some
interesting facts that I didn't know but
uh so we are going to meet on this
excuse me this bill next week um there
is an amendment coming forward that we
will see today that representative
Maguire is going to offer and the uh
clerk's office is rule that is kind of
non- gerine based on what we've been
given so we will have a hearing next
Wednesday in full Finance at 11
p.m. did I say PM you I I'm serious
about PM you know because we're GNA be
here all day before that but no 11
am um are there any more questions for
yeah I wanted to go back to page 33 if I
could sure yeah all right so the we'll
skip over the 65% and go to 10% for the
Community reinvestment Fund why why is
that in um yes that is created within
this so that we can make make sure that
there is some money going back to our
communities for sewers um for other
things so that we can support the
communities that um that really need
some help so Water and Sewer expansion
Pro uh projects legal aid for expansion
of cannabis convictions grants to assist
Farmers entering the Cannabis market and
cannabis related research and
development um these are all areas that
as there's more understanding and and
more um that is happening within the
market that's good to have the reseearch
and and devel velopment but honestly I
think one of the biggest Parts is that
um one of the challenges we have for new
Housing Development is the lack of new
water and sewer and um being able to
help in that especially if it's if
you're doing this and helping out
communities so that they can have more
water and sewer and build more homes um
that that is a big benefit and we want
to make sure that we're bringing
Community benefit as well um Beyond just
the fact that we don't want more mothers
having their sons um have cannabis that
they bought on on the street that was
contaminated with fentanyl let's also
address some of the real world issues
that we can do with State
funds yeah I think we probably have
water sewer stuff elsewhere in the state
okay so let's go on to that's so this is
a new fund I didn't realize that yes
that is created on the bottom of page 33
yeah I see that now all right good so
let's go on to the next one um well
we've already talked about the next one
uh number four 5 % for broad Aid to
municipalities where they have a store
right okay so this is a kickback similar
to uh meals and and rooms rentals tax
guess as opposed to the idea of just
taking 1% of whatever is collected off
the top and giving it to the communities
this actually this depending on the tax
rate I know it's not going to be called
a tax but depending on that rate it's
close to the Same by delivering that
five that 5% back okay and then uh next
one Public
Safety um for drug recognition experts
and driving enforcement and so on
um
okay do you do you think this bill
causes such problems no I think that
most of the people who may not use
cannabis in the most responsible manner
don't really care whether it's legal or
not when they purchase it um if you
don't care about um consuming and
driving you probably don't care about
WEA or not it's legal within the state
so that will help address an a problem
that we already have in our
communities okay so and then the last
one is the
um HHS children's Behavioral Health is
that just
another you know nice to have kind of
thing well I mean that's one of the
areas when you look at it and if you
have children that have ongoing issues
they may be more likely that if they
haven't addressed those as they become
adults they me choose to self-medicate
with something and rather than dealing
with people um trying to trying to deal
with a problem let's try and make sure
that we're addressing our kids and
making sure that we're taking care of
them um especially because this is the
sort of thing that can be used for more
intensive children that need more help
and are the ones that really are most at
risk for negative lifetime
outcomes so let me just say in general
I'm opposed to all of this kind of
automatic spending our job as the
finance committee is to take the state's
resour financial resources and allocate
them to the current needs of the of the
state and we do this you know every two
years and I think you know reasonably
well and all of these kind of people the
behavioral health and the drug and
alcohol program etc etc they all come to
to us with their needs and and we
balance those with our resources and
putting specific numbers we don't know
that 5% or $5 million or any particular
number today is the number that's needed
five years from now right or even next
year and so what this does is it gives
the people that spend this money an
expectation that I will be getting X for
my program and and often we have to
change X to something else and and it
just adds to The Angst of the of the
whole situation so so I'm personally
just I mean this is discussion but I'm
I'm I'm opposed to all this kind of kind
of
stuff with that I'm not my question
would be in something that you don't
know the size of the market how do you
know how much to give for the drug
recognition experts and
others right but we we certainly know
that better the year before we need it
than we do today when there's not going
to be any sales for two years you see
what I mean so so saying these are round
numbers 5% 10% the right number is
probably 6.7% or you know some not
percents but I mean some number of
millions of dollars and so we certainly
the year before we need to spend the
money that's the best time to decide how
to spend the money not
today I look forward to working you with
you when it's uh no longer federally
prohibited just to put it right into
General funds if that's the best
idea further questions for
representative
lean seeing none thank you thank you I
would like to call in representative
Maguire to offer his
Amendment so I think this is
and again we will be holding a public
hearing um on this amendment has hand
Wednesday
yeah it's
crazy right would you like me to sit
okay all right so this is
um let me just talk about slightly
what's what's going on behind the scenes
is that
um the uh we're in discussions with both
uh the senate in particular Senator Abus
and the governor's representative um
Harold
Parker over what their requirements are
for this kind of
legislation and
um the
the the political reality is that that
in any situation any negotiation it's
the person who cares the least who has
the most power okay the one who's
willing to walk away is the one who can
make decisions in in any
negotiation and traditionally in this
area that's the
governor um with the second Senate being
second secondary and the house tertiary
because we pass things year after year
after year and it stopped somewhere
along the way in those other bodies so
because they want this the least they
essentially have the most um political
power so this amendment is the one
handed to me by the senator abis and he
created it in in close con consultation
with the governor now just before this
hearing I hear from Senator abis there
are more changes coming so so this is
the basic structure they want but
there's going to be you know detail this
detail that other
changes
um
and if you want to ask me personally if
I think this is the best way to um to
handle this situation the answer is no
um but if you ask me do I think the
amendment from representative
Leon uh will get through the next two
steps the answer is also no right so so
I believe them when they tell me this is
what they want and very little changes
from this are possible now the amendment
as it comes to us specifically among and
I read off those requirements from them
last time right but among those
requirements are not the financial
aspects right so the the stuff we have
just been talking about the 10% the 5%
all that kind of stuff those are not as
far as I can understand key to those
other people so those are things we
certainly can change and I actually I'll
just do it I guess if that's the sense
of the commit I mean what's the sense of
the committee as far as those it are
concerned do you agree with me that that
budgeting should not happen in in the
rsas it should happen in our
committee I see some nodding
nodding not so sure
shrugs okay so you know so I when I come
up with that is not a key feature for
those other group groups as far as I can
understand so I would take remove those
things okay
so I did reach out to the governor today
and invited him to join us at 1:00 but I
don't see him there yet so
uh but there are a number of things uh
and again we're going to discuss this at
a public hearing next week but uh some
of the things that come to mind that are
non-budgetary in this is U the senator
when he was here he said he wanted
people to
U be charged with with a misdemeanor if
they were caught for a second time you
said that was a line in the sand for him
is that how do you feel about that
particular I dis I strongly dislike that
okay so so my attitude on this whole
thing so all right let's go back to my
original comment about when you don't
care you have more more negotiation
Mobility so for for the past 15 years up
to two weeks ago I was in the camp of
I'll I'll vote for whatever it is right
I'm I'm in favor of liberal Li alization
of this of this area um but now I've
started to actually read these
bills and they're full of junk like like
what you just mentioned you know so I'm
moving toward the don't care category
and therefore maybe have more say I
don't know but but the point is but the
point is this particular thing is really
does bother me because I don't want as
part of a liberalization effort to have
more people in jail for for cannabis
than we have today I mean it doesn't
make any sense at all right and so um
and so the situation today is really not
that bad because because it's it's all
either violations or maybe Class B
misdemeanor which is fine only and and
essentially not only that but the but
the law enforcement is not enforcing it
right so I I spoke to uh police in my
town and they tell me that 20 years ago
they were making 400 arrests a year of
all kinds in my town and um today it's
about
125 and a big difference is is cannabis
they used to they used to if they saw a
pipe in your car and it had a little
sticky residue in it okay you're going
to jail you know but today don't even
bother you know you could have a a
shopping bag from Maine you know they
don't care right so um so not only is it
only a violation today but it's a non
non enforced violation in the most for
the most part so so going back to a
class A misdemeanor I mean that's really
silly
um but you
know so I would take that out if it was
up to me
representative Griffin some
comments I I guess my comment
is this isn't really our
Amendment this is a Amendment of the
other body
socalled and I don't know what business
we have with it I don't know why we're
doing
it can I I'll explain all right let me
explain so the thing
is what the other body can do or as I
understand it is they can pass this
whatever we give them on the floor okay
but they can't
debate you know um this fund that fun
10%
5% misdemeanors all this kind of stuff
on the floor of the Senate right and and
they can't debate it obviously you can't
debate with the governor it's it's a yes
or no so if we're get into details on
what might actually
pass this is the place this is almost
the only place where that can happen um
and and so if you don't want sort of a
back room take it or leave it these are
the features kind of thing if you want
to actually talk about specifics it has
to be here in public and I that's what I
would prefer to to see happen so that's
why we're doing it this
way further comments
Jerry no they answered my question I I
I'm not I'm not for all those separate
sure so I have a question representative
Maguire as we saw when the senator was
here a week ago the amount of money
they're looking for is substantially
higher than the bill that is in the
house
and I'm just seeing it now page 37 of
the numbers on starting on line
27 9.6 mil8 mil 500,000 I think it adds
million do we have 37 at the bottom line
27 yeah so those are twoyear numbers I
think versus a onee number other twoyear
one one is one the
2024 June of 24 right but that's the
first year which I think is equivalent
to this other Bill the other one is for
the next year and and uh
right so whereas I think the the current
bill is just for the one year right then
year
the eight in the first bill our the
house position is 8 million for 25 in
this vill they've got 9 million for 24
and 8 million for 25 and that's oh okay
I guess and I'm following up on what you
said earlier which I certainly agree
with that we have a responsibility to
manage the state's funds as best we can
and there's a lot lot of money here at
stake absolutely um before we receive
even a dime of
profit right so it looks
like this bill accelerates this the
startup of this program you see what I
mean because because in represent June
24 June of 24 right whereas
representative lons doesn't spend the 8
million until June
2025 what are we saying that the the
amendment you're offering at the first
year will be 9.6 and the second year 8
million that's what it sounds like
that's what it looks like to me so I'm
assuming that the source of these
numbers is the Liquor Commission so we
could maybe uh ask him some detail he's
shaking his head no no okay we won't put
you on the spot today all right I'll
I'll I'll try to answer that question in
more detail or get yeah you could have
that for a public yeah good good point
at the next because that's a significant
amount of money difference yeah and I
don't disagree with representative
Maguire on the percentages for funds I
think anyone that comes before us should
make an uh a request and have a budget
before we just hand out 5% or 35%
whatever we there should be a budget
there's a lot of money there too yeah
for potentially I'll ask about that
yeah further questions of Representative
McGuire and his Amendment
chairman wer I mean we're sort of
jumping the gun non gerine if there are
any questions we'd try to get them
answered before next Wednesday but
yeah representative cells
anything thank you Mr chair uh what
percentage fee is in this bill for the
uh oh for that the state would get yeah
let you find it because uh CU ours is
like what 10% and yeah well and I think
it's slightly higher and I believe in uh
representative Lan's bill it was 10% and
it would be waved for people that had
medical use but I don't believe that's
the case here I believe it yeah that
they would not wave it for medical use
and I believe that that's sort of a
detail that we can get into that it
wasn't in the governor's list of of
musthave kind of things right
so my issue being that uh if it's higher
I believe I saw a figure of 12 a
half% uh that's again non-competitive in
my opinion and uh also if they're going
to charge the medical uh users that's
kind of a another I don't think that
that would be right for for medical use
to to charge them to make money off of
that so
sure represent evil are there ATC in the
Senate
version is there a pathway for atc's in
the Senate version I think so yeah no I
I haven't read it through yet yeah I
part so I would encourage anybody that's
out here today to come next Wednesday
chairman wer is generally very uh
receptive to questions and then the
division will hold a work session after
the public hearing and we'll take all
sorts of policy questions at that time
and budgetary questions yeah when you
when you read multiple bills it's this
the details tend to you know was this
and this one or not in that one you know
all that kindu that's why we do the side
by side Mr Hoff and I see you smiling do
you really want to put together a side
by side
or I haven't started um yeah that's I
thought it just needs cleaning up but
I'm not sure how to do all three no I'll
I'll I'll answer that question I'll
think about that for next week okay
thank you so representative Griffin I I
have a procedure question so the hearing
next week's for a non-gain
Amendment so when
is uh representative mcu's new Amendment
to the amendment no but you want to
change the percentages
right go Joe go ahead Jo I would say
once we have the hearing on this non-
derain amendment we can then make
amendments to the non- that's what I was
trying to clarify that was my thought
too
y I know some of you have come a long
way know anything that someone wants to
add I'm sure commissioner Mica would
love to speak to us
now uh do you have you a question though
for you has anybody approached you about
uh fiscal note for this new Amendment or
I know there was some numbers that have
been thrown out there but is there a no
Mr Hoffman okay all right
thanks all right well we'll probably see
you all next Wednesday at 11:
a.m. I want to thank the gentle lady
from Dair for her hard work
and see you next week okay I predicted 2
o'
w